last night at the Calgary underground
Film Festival I saw under the shadow the
movie is Iranian though it wasn't made
in Iran it's in Farsi and it takes place
in Tehran in 1988 as the iran-iraq war
reached its peak and is a film that I'm
having a bit of trouble trying to
describe not because I don't know what
it's about but more because I can't
decide how I want to describe it what
layer of the film I want to present
because like all good horror films its
horror isn't just a creature but is the
ideas that that creature represents on
the surface level it is a supernatural
horror with a monster who terrorizes the
protagonists who tried desperately to
figure out how to fight back a bit of a
bottle movie meets ghost story on a
deeper level there is a private horror
about the personal and cultural
anxieties that the monster represents
however just saying it that way feels
like a disservice to the film I mean
saying that horror films are built on
metaphor is a pretty pedestrian
observation saying that monsters and
movies represent things that aren't
literally monsters is like okay
congratulations you understand horror as
a genre that's what a horror movie is so
what I want to stress is the level to
which understanding the metaphor of the
monster is so very key to understanding
the threat of the monster in this film
the xenomorph an alien is dangerous and
scary because it's made of teeth and
death and darkness and silence it kills
people
the sexual dimension of the film the
themes of penetration and violation are
largely subtextual they're not something
that the characters engage with much
outside the context of the xenomorph in
contrast to the monster and under the
shadow is the patriarchy and even though
it's not put in that exact word the
shadow of patriarchy looms large over
the lives of the characters it is a
movie about being small in a large world
about living in the shadow of things
that are so big so out of scope with a
single individual that they become
almost supernatural the main character
shidae lives in the shadow of the
Iranian Cultural Revolution the shadow
of the Ayatollah the shadow of the Iran
an Iraq war the shadow of
Americanization and on a more intimate
level the shadow of depression and
anxiety about her place in a large and
complex world her relationship with her
mother and her daughter an idealist and
a revolutionary in her youth shidae now
finds herself in a world where her
rights and freedoms are ever diminishing
where old superstitions have regained
their strength and are exerting their
power the fact that this is a ghost
story of sorts is important it is
poignant that the threat is mythology -
the thing that threatens today is a
cultural artifact the movie rides
feelings of anxiety depression
frustration and inadequacy and it rides
them hard large segments of the film are
basically the encapsulation of a panic
attack in film form the filmmakers make
heavy use of displace sounds to put the
audience off-kilter and it works it
works really well
the final notes of the film are
complicated I've spent quite a bit of
time digesting it at this point and the
ending is a bluff it's a very sad ending
wearing the skin of a kind of happy
ending this is intentional there is a
release of tension an escape from the
immediate threats but can you ever truly
escape yourself your past your family
can you escape the very culture that you
exist in can you escape myth itself